vamos a hacer algunos problemas sobre el
decaimiento exponencial porque realmente
la forma de que se te hagan muy fáciles
es simplemente práctica y sentirse de
una manera confortable con la idea de la
fórmula general que voy a escribir de
nuevo la fórmula general me dice que la
cantidad de un elemento que está
decayendo en algún punto del tiempo es
decir n es la cantidad de este elemento
que depende de ti de un punto en el
tiempo esto es exactamente igual que la
cantidad inicial que hay de este
elemento es decir en el sub índice 0
esta es la cantidad inicial ok que
multiplican a la exponencial que
multiplica al exponencial elevada a la
menos cam que a la menos acá en donde el
valor de cam es un valor específico para
un cierto elemento que tiene una cierta
vida media y bueno algunas veces no te
dan
esta vida media de hecho creo que esta
es una situación bastante interesante
imagínate que tenemos un elemento y
déjame darte su fórmula am se me ocurre
pensar en un elemento en el cual sepamos
esta constante acá pero no sepamos su
vida media y vamos a decir que a este
elemento mágico por aquí
tiene un valor de can tiene un valor de
cam
iguala
perdona es que he comido muchas nueces y
mi garganta está un poco seca
este valor de acá es igual a 0.05 vamos
a decir ok
y bueno si este es el valor de cam
entonces la ecuación me va a quedar de
la siguiente manera en el dtm n de tm es
exactamente igual a en el subíndice 0
que multiplica a la función exponencial
y éste es positivo por lo tanto aquí me
va a quedar menos 0.05 ok estoy
sustituyendo el valor que nos dan de
camps por el tiempo ok y yo lo que
quiero es saber cuál es la vida media de
este elemento que tenemos aquí y es más
deben ponerlo con este color yo lo que
quiero saber es cuál es la vida la vida
media día ok
pues como lo resolvemos es decir para
que te que pongamos aquí quiero una t
que pongamos aquí vamos a obtener que la
cantidad de inicial se va a dividir a la
mitad en esta ecuación es decir
empezamos con una cierta cantidad y como
no la sabemos podemos poner en el
subíndice cero pero bueno también
podremos poner cualquier valor aquí tal
vez a 100 voy a suponer in déjame
cambiar de color que en ese subíndice 0
es igual a 100 para no hacer esto tan
tan abstracto y bueno date cuenta que el
valor que elijamos es indistinto porque
no estoy tomando este valor de una
manera aleatoria podría dejarlo en
abstracto es decir en el subíndice 0
pero va a ser más fácil si ponemos algún
valor aquí decimos que empezamos con 100
y entonces a ampo me quedaría esta parte
de mi ecuación bueno pues la cantidad
inicial vale 100
entonces me va a quedar déjame cambiar
de color me va a quedar
cien veces cien veces he elevado a la
menos 0.05 que multiplica a t y de hecho
es justo lo que queremos un valor para t
esto va a ser exactamente igual que en y
bueno del otro lado tenemos la cantidad
que nosotros queremos pero lo que
queremos saber es la vida media y la
vida media es el tiempo en el cual la
cantidad inicial se divide a la mitad es
decir que esto va a ser igual a 50 a 50
y bueno de aquí habrá que despejar el
tiempo y para eso se me ocurre que lo
primero que podemos hacer es dividir
todo entre 100 y me va a quedar que es
elevado a la menos 0.05 por t ok esto va
a ser igual a un medio ok
y bueno si ahora sacó el logaritmo
natural de ambos lados
voy a sacar a logaritmo natural de este
lado y también voy a sacar el logaritmo
natural de éste
entonces que me va a quedar bueno
recordemos lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado el logaritmo natural de m elevado
a lo que sea es esto es lo que sea por
lo tanto de aquí solamente voy a obtener
am y déjenme cambiar de ecuador de aquí
solamente voy a obtener menos 0.05 por t
ok y de este otro lado me va a quedar
que es lo mismo que el logaritmo natural
de 1
y si de aquí quiero despejar el tema
aunque voy a obtener voy a obtener que
te den es exactamente igual al logaritmo
natural de un medio de un medio
ok esto dividido entre menos 0.05 lo
único que estoy haciendo es dividiendo
todo entre esta cantidad y ahora si yo
saco por acá mi calculadora déjame
traerla por acá ok entonces qué es lo
que va a pasar cuando él yo quiero hacer
el cálculo con esta ecuación y puedo de
hecho se me ocurre una cosa muchísimo
creo que podríamos regresar aquí antes
de bajar un poco en la pantalla déjame
bajar un poco la pantalla para que
entonces am hagamos un pequeño truco lo
cual me va a facilitar las cuentas en la
calculadora
si yo aquí en lugar de este menos le
pongo aquí un más que multiplicó todo
por menos uno el menos me quedaría justo
acá arriba lo único que hice fue pasar
el menos para arriba pero cuando yo
tengo menos el organismo natural de algo
esto es exactamente lo mismo
el logaritmo natural del inverso
multiplicativo de lo que está aquí
adentro eso siempre lo podemos hacer
cuando tenemos un menos antes del
logaritmo y me quedaría que t es igual
al logaritmo natural de 2 que es el
inverso multiplicativo de un medio entre
0.05 y ahora si nosotros traemos para
acá nuestra calculadora y hacemos esta
cuenta que me va a quedar
déjame traerla para acá voy a decir que
quiero el logaritmo natural de 2 ok ya
estoy dividirlo entre a 0.05 y la
respuesta es 13.86 perfecto ya tengo el
tiempo esto es lo mismo que 13.86 y es
justo lo que yo quería la vida media y
bueno voy a suponer que está dado en
años en años porque casi siempre estos
problemas se dan en años
ahora bien podría no estar dado en años
pero cualquier cantidad de tiempo que
nosotros tengamos aquí de una manera
sencilla la podemos convertir a años
y bueno obtuvimos este resultado gracias
a que nosotros am y dejamos subir un
poco de la pantalla empezamos con esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí con esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí y nosotros nos
dimos cuenta que ya teníamos el valor de
cam y después aquí puse una cierta
cantidad la que ya mismo ocurrió a bien
podremos poner que en el subíndice cero
sea 200.000 o equis y entonces si fuera
x aquí tendría que poner la mitad es
decir x entre 2 y ya con esto lo único
que teníamos que hacer era despejar el
valor de t con mucho cuidado y ya
tenemos la respuesta así que qué te
parece si hacemos un problema más de
este tipo para sentirnos muy cómodos con
la fórmula original voy a bajar un poco
la pantalla para hacer el siguiente
problema se me ocurre hacer este
siguiente problema digamos que tenemos
una vida media una vida
a media de un mes de um
un mes y entonces a no no no no mejor
voy a quitar esto y es que en el vídeo
pasado ya vimos cómo encontrar la
constante cam
dada la vida media así que si tú tienes
problemas con ello puede regresar a ese
vídeo pasado entonces en lugar de tener
una vida media de un mes voy a decir que
camps a vale 0.001 y bueno estoy
haciendo esto por cuestiones de tiempo
lo que quiero es el problema un poco más
rápido de todas maneras quiero que
recuerdes que en el vídeo pasado nos
dimos cuenta de cómo encontrar la
constante camps utilizando los datos de
la vida media y bueno si k es igual a
0.001 entonces como me queda mi ecuación
n dtm en el dtm va a ser igual a
subíndice 0 ok que multiplica a el
elevado a la menos camps es decir menos
0.001
0.001 que a su vez multiplica al tiempo
ok ahora vamos a suponer que después de
1000 años y eso lo voy a poner con este
color se me ocurre decir que después
después
de mil años mil años
solamente me quedan 500 gramos
me quedan 500 gramos de este compuesto
mi pregunta es con cuánto iniciamos es
decir esencialmente lo que queremos
saber es cuál es el valor de n subíndice
0 y para eso vamos a utilizar estos
datos en esta ecuación así que vamos a
ponerlo
si yo aquí calculó cuánto es n de 1000 n
de 1000 ok porque este dato lo tengo
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
en el subíndice 0
estoy sustituyendo en esta fórmula que
multiplica a el elevado a la menos 0.001
que a su vez esto multiplica el tiempo
pero el tiempo son 1000 años por lo
tanto esto que multiplica a mil a mil ok
muy bien dejan lo mejor ponerlo con un
asterisco ok
estos dos están multiplicando y esto a
su vez es exactamente igual
pues la cantidad de final que son 500
gramos después de mil años vamos a tener
500 gramos de este elemento y bueno lo
único que hay que hacer de aquí es
despejar en el subíndice 0 y creo que no
está tan difícil déjame bajar un poco la
pantalla para terminar de resolver este
problema se ahora aquí lo que quiero es
despejar en el subíndice cero que voy a
obtener bueno que n subíndice 0 por el
elevado a la 01.00 uno por mil bueno
pues esto es una milésima parte de mil
lo cual es menos 1 eso está muy sencillo
entonces en el subíndice 0 que
multiplica a en elevado al menos 1 esto
es lo mismo que 500 gramos ok y si ahora
multiplicó todo por él me va a quedar
que en el subíndice 0
es lo mismo que 500 x en ok y habrá que
calcular
así que déjenme sacar por aquí a la
calculadora ok la tengo por aquí voy a
multiplicar a 500 x
por el elevado a la primera potencia
elevado a la primera potencia y esto es
lo mismo que en mil 359 gramos entonces
déjame ponerlo aquí esto es lo mismo que
mil 359 gramos os lo queremos ver en
kilogramos es un kilogramo con 359
gramos ok entonces justo el valor de n
sub zero que yo quería
este valor de aquí es mil 359 gramos con
esto empecé ahora como veis en este
momento quiero que te des cuenta que lo
más importante es regresar a esta déjame
bajar un poco más la pantalla a esta
fórmula que tenemos aquí si tú tienes un
examen de química o tienes que resolver
algún problema que tiene el profesor lo
más importante es recordar está
expresión que tenemos aquí está de aquí
y curiosamente esto aplica a un montón
de cosas que ya en un futuro veremos
por ejemplo el interés compuesto pero en
este caso la casería positiva aunque
esencialmente es la misma fórmula y
bueno también hay un montón de cosas que
esta fórmula describe pero eso sí ahora
lo que sabemos es que una de ellas es el
decaimiento radioactivo pero bueno
regresando la idea es que con esta
fórmula intentes obtener la mayor
cantidad de constantes que puedas y ya
con eso tengas una expresión la cual
puedas utilizar para resolver lo que te
estén preguntando y bueno espero que te
haya dado los suficientes ejemplos para
que tengas unas buenas herramientas para
resolver problemas de este tipo pero
házmelo saber yo estoy feliz realizando
estos problemas